negli episodi precedenti questa è la mia
marchi ci
vado ma sto con te in finché non finisce
mai
la vj originals ragazzi sono con la
valigia da penso un quarto d'ora e non
sto trovando la lobby dell'hotel è tutto
troppo grosso
la reception
ma quello ragano nel tornello delle
giostre non stiamo andando sul blu
tornado di gardaland e la reception una
reception con la fileni non l'ho mai
vista sono partito alle undici del
mattino sono le undici di sera
2 interoute madonna conte grosso
sostanza
[Musica]
chiamate fuori come stanno messi
a bello alto figo ma adesso basta
parlare di me parliamo dello termine la
prima mattina dove mi sveglio ad un
orario decente dopo quattro giorni non
mi riprenderò perché suoi mutande
vediamo come si vede las vegas di prima
mattina ai affannoso dal in testa su
gold
è una ragazza deciso di fidarmi in
attimo in piscina perché effettivamente
lo meritava molto carino faranno verso
il caesars palace per lo studente di
scrivere quanto è grossa tutta sta roba
che sto vedendo solo che dal video non
si capisce è troppo grosso stop mostra
come faccia c'è troppa roba che cazzo è
un hotel
amalfi ma tutto a posto qua credo che si
giochi a briscola un'ora che cammino
sono ancora dentro evidentemente entro
il caesars palace non sono mai uscito ci
sarà una fine prima o poi non so
altrimenti torno in italia camminando
potenti non si esce
no che sogno non mi ricordavo più il
cielo ho 32 anni fa sempre ridere la
gente che in italia ti giudica per come
sei vestito e 49 i ragazzi noi come lo
chiamiamo questo palazzo o non lo so
palazzo va bene siamo arrivati al punto
di vedere che porcate fanno in italiano
del green g in arrivo ragazzi
[Musica]
in sostanza è un c
è un centro commerciale con l'acqua di
una venezia sotto un tetto che sembra
non ce l'ho ma non è un cielo questo è
il tempo di pinto lo facevo meglio io
tra l'altro si effettivamente hanno
messo un cielo finto o è la fontana dice
volevano fare una roba tipo la fontana
di trevi e non ci sono riusciti
ragazzone conservato il primo cartellone
fatto da mia nonna
sì raga ma il mio giardiniere starò ma
la faceva meglio c'è il menù dei flussi
e questi sono i prezzi un pezzo uno solo
arriva a costare anche 15 dollari 15
dollari europa ata rumori e palla vedere
la venuta del signore quella gigante non
questo e ancora già questo è grande non
mi dico quadri sono altri con i palazzi
per the muppet bai ming e timing è
quindi ragazzi una volta scoperta las
vegas ho ripreso la macchina e sono
andato dritto a san diego
siamo arrivati al momento che
devo salutare la mia bambina e stato un
viaggio incredibile grazie zia
ti chiamerò
nancy penso e appena torno in italia mi
compro una mustang che prima cosa che
faccio una veramente incredibile allora
ragazzi sono stati diego questa la
insegno io quando c'è il free breakfast
si prende tutto ok cioè voi prendete
proprio tutta la cucina ho mangiato 62
waffle dune prima tappa voluto farmi
malissimo qua san diego c'è little italy
con le bandiere ci siamo
vediamo il resto nonna minimo anche i
ragazzi rovare filippi ragazzina tutto a
posto scorsa
ok raga allora ho camminato per 2 metri
e ho visto questo insomma non è proprio
una zattera niente stava mangiando ma
hanno deciso di unirsi al tavolo hai
perduto il panettone e grazie ha portato
un pezzo di pane gigante complimenti ai
gabbiani di san diego spese la granita
alla gomma da masticare e già il colore
fa ridere prova
incredibile sa di cittadinanza italiana
terza diversamente da los angeles san
francisco qua il ponte ci sono delle
casette sopra un po come se qualcuno
dovesse andarci in vacanza sopra molto
figo o ancora la granita alla gomma da
masticare che tra si è sciolta forse è
meglio così se siamo arrivati alla fine
della spiaggia di san diego dove c'è
questa roccia anche la gente chiama
vvd usa avvenuto a mangiare in un
ristorante italiano allora non so che è
rischioso lo so però stasera proviamo la
pena se vi devo dire la verità non
sembra neanche male
giuro
ospiti però non è che fa schifo
come
per aver sono avvistamenti
ed eccoci all'ultima tappa di questo
video che non ho raggiunto con la
macchina con il treno perchè l'avevo già
lasciata purtroppo e arriviamo
finalmente da una nostra vecchia amica
los angeles elsie pd io sono tante
perché siamo era un po che non lo so
siamo a venice
è rimasto tutto uguale e questo mi rende
veramente felice siccome siamo tornati a
venice beach non potevo non mostrare le
mie doti e devo fare
ok forse non è il massimo
raga
minchia che bello comunque qua è pieno
di roba piga è tutto come l'avevo
lasciato sono troppo contento di questi
si sa può succedere qualsiasi cosa la
mia vita ma se torno qui è tutto uguale
a che bella los angeles tra gara mi
mancava l'altra mobilità della
california proprio california
gentile
e non si può avere ti senti così a
rischio l'acciacco di barton lavora che
brutto essere vecchio tutti quanti si
fermano sempre su quella di michael
jackson non si ricavano proprio gli
altri
la cosa incredibile
raga son tornato
mamma mia
questo posto è attualmente tra i 10
posti più pericolosi d'america di
chinese theatre qua si tengono gli oscar
dicono che un sacco di gente prende a
schiaffi la gente quando forse l'ultimo
pillola o gen crolla forse l'ultimo
video l'avevo fatto nel 2015 qui madonna
incredibile no ragazzi a hollywood in
space con mark player pazzesco poi
trattano gli youtube era esattamente
come fanno in italia l'unico posto a los
angeles che non aveva ancora visto da
vicino era appunto la scritta di
hollywood ma proprio perché non ci si
può avvicinare così tanto è vietato
dalla legge ma nonostante questo ho
voluto vedere quanto più vicino
possibile riuscivo ad arrivare quindi ho
fatto la scalata di un certo punto ci si
ferma con la macchina perché non si può
proseguire per andare all insegna di
hollywood si deve andare per forza a
piedi però non è una strada dedicata all
insegna con una strada normale per
chiusa al traffico solo se veramente
stranissima sono attualmente 37 gradi e
il 7 di aprile
37 gradi non esistono il 7 di aprile già
arrivare qua è stato un miracolo perché
la macchina si è dovuta fermare prima ma
adesso arriva ma la scritta
[Musica]
benvenuti un'altra puntata di mtv creeps
è questa qua è casa mia e adesso ve la
faccio vedere entriamo
ok ragazzi arriva una parte dove la
gente si ferma la scritta e lì non so se
la vedete giusta casa qua e poi a un
certo punto di vista tutto privato
perché è tutto chiuso però io me ne
fotto e dentro lo stesso vediamo che
succede non so se sono in un punto dove
non dovrei e probabilmente mi
arresteranno tra 5 minuti arriva
qualcuno infine e spero solo quelle
comunque la scritta e quella e provo a
seguire il percorso per raggiungere non
ne sono sicuro c'è questa è una delle
attrazioni più conosciute al mondo
celerate ralmente al mondo e non c'è
nessuno minchia ragazza in costruendo
una casa qua adesso dopo qua lo regala
quanto costa ma giusto
data anche la sedia ok ragazzi allora
sono arrivato questo è il punto più
vicino dove puoi arrivare alla scritta a
tranne che se non ci vuole andare dietro
però c'è una specie di traliccio questo
è esattamente il punto estremo perché
dopo deve iniziare a scalare la collina
e quindi dopo è tutta di tutto cespugli
e lo fa niente se poi inizia
arrampicarti diventi nemico delle baie
della cia quindi non lo faccio perché
per adesso sono solo nemico della
polizia ma proprio ci sono 62 cartelli
che ti dicono che se per caso ti azzardi
a pestare un cespuglietto oltre quella
roba lì sono cazzi tuoi
e con questi capelli inguardabili vi
dico che anche los angeles questa volta
giunge al termine ma non me ne sto
tornando a casa per la prima volta sono
in aeroporto si vede dal fatto che ho
infilato le robe perché sto andando come
vi avevo già detto alle hawaii perché le
hawaii fanno sempre parte degli stati
uniti quindi prendo un aereo interno
della alaska airlines che prenderà la
white devi usare l'alaska airlines che
non ha senso che prima non era proprio
tutti madaba però le hawaii ve ne farò
vedere nel prossimo video ragazzi ho
messo un piede fuori dall'aereo sono
ancora nell'aeroporto ero forte delle
hawaii e questo
55 se questo nell'aeroporto della
wireless e dini che vogliono dentro la
no vabbè sento parlare di questa terra
da sempre